i i talked with falcons quarterback matt
ryan yesterday about that and other
issues and one of the things i asked him
about was in this abnormal year um what
advice would you give
to teammates who may be wrestling with a
question that we've seen so many already
resolve
with a decision to opt out what would
you say to your teammates who are
considering that same path here's matt
ryan from yesterday
well i think everybody's circumstances
are different right and and you know you
have to do what's best for yourself and
and for your family and and your loved
ones around you and and i think that
uh you know if if you're around people
who are at risk you know i'd encourage
you to to really think long and hard
about it but
for me specifically i feel like i'm in a
situation where
you know my day-to-day is is not
surrounded by people who are at high
risk and we're able to kind of
uh you know bubble our little world and
and make sure that you know we're being
as safe as possible so i feel
comfortable uh you know coming in and
getting ready to to start this season
for the first time since your last year
at boston college no pre-season games
how different will this year be for you
than all of your other nfl seasons as
you prepare for week one without the
benefit of going through the motions
even if you don't play in a preseason
game you go through the motions you go
to the locker room you get your uniform
on you you get used to how it's going to
be how different will it be without that
this year yeah i think you know it will
be different i i you know i kind of like
the the preseason games to be able to
get out there and knock off some of that
you know rust that you have to be able
to
you know go go through it like you said
go through your routine make sure that
you know you're doing the things you
need to do and and you kind of have
things ironed out we're not going to
have that luxury uh but you know i think
dan is is putting together dan quinn is
putting together a really good schedule
for us to try and
you know simulate as much as we can on
our own you know what that experience is
going to be like and
you know i think it's more important for
a guy like me i'm in year 13 i i think
it's
you know it's it's going to be easier
for a guy like myself having been
through so many different situations so
many years so many you know games played
and feeling comfortable in those but for
our rookies and for our young guys who
have have not had that experience you
know i think we've got to help them out
as much as we can and try and make them
feel as comfortable as possible because
you know when when we kick it off
against seattle week one you know that
that game is just as important as week
17 and uh it means just as much
you know this season is going to
present plenty of advantages and
disadvantages but it's got to be an
advantage
to have a starting quarterback with the
same team not changing teams like a tom
brady in tampa but you're with the same
team you've been there it's got to make
it so much easier to get ready for the
season without the benefit of a
preseason
i'd like to think so you know i i think
having the same coordinator a lot of
continuity within the building
all of those things
make going through experiences like this
that are unique uh it makes it easier
because you know you have that
you know you have that foundation built
with with these guys where you
understand
uh how to work with each other and you
know i think that's going to benefit us
i really hope it benefits us
uh and it gives us some kind of
advantage
the full matt ryan interview available
at the pft pm podcast and chris you know
we've talked about this a few times the
falcons finished last year six and two
usually that's the kind of team that we
keep our eyes on or the possibility they
can build on they went to san francisco
and beat the 49ers in a game that the
49ers very much needed down the stretch
and all the talk about the buccaneers
and the saints and tom brady and drew
brees that this sets up yeah perfectly
for the falcons to come in
and stun people and be that team that's
off the radar that while the buccaneers
and the saints are cannibalizing each
other in week one the falcons get off to
a good start now they play the seahawks
so
it's going to be tough to go 1-0 but you
know if the falcons can knock off the
seahawks out of the gates we see that
every year there's some outcome the
first week of the season that makes us
say holy crap
i'm not going to overlook the falcons oh
no i don't think we should you know i
you you explained all the right reasons
and don't overlook them in week one i
mean dan quinn he came from seattle
nobody knows that team and what they do
better than him so and i think the big
thing is what i mean
the damn team in atlanta is talented you
know talent has not been the issue the
last two years it's been surviving the
injury bug i mean they've just been
absolutely ravaged by it so that's been
the biggest issue and you know you look
at it from there and you know a lot of
things that jump out to me there but
certainly
you know their defense you know grady
jarrett dante fowler jr there we know
the linebackers kean o'neal hopefully
he's healthy the offense the receivers
todd gurley can he help out i mean
there's a lot of things to like about
this football team and they got a lot of
carryover there's not a lot of new
pieces they got some young guys in the
offensive line they got to develop but
i'm with you mike you know these are
this is one of those teams that's you
know totally under the radar just just
sitting there and a lot of talent on the
football team and a team that yeah i
don't think the coveted 19 year is going
to affect them as much as maybe like you
said in the interview the bucks and
anything like that so uh i'm with you i
think they can be dangerous and you know
the last thing too
preseason football
people i think are making a little bit
bigger of a deal than that about that
than i think there should be
you know i understand it's important but
it's more important for some of the back
end guys for a guy like matt ryan he
kind of just talked about it
it's like important for him because hey
he wants to go out and just like go
through the rehearsal a little bit play
a few series and get out that's all he
cares about it's not about like oh i
need to play and do all that but the
last few years in the nfl preseason
football nobody freaking plays anymore i
mean the starters play such limited reps
that it's hard to get a feel for teams
from what you see in the preseason and
then like try to evaluate and say oh i
saw this in the preseason and that'll
carry over to the regular season there
was a time when that was real now i
don't think so and so i don't know if
it's going to change things a whole lot
as far as football regular season
football is concerned this year
all right matt ryan uh was also asked
the question of whether he would take a
super bowl ring or a hall of fame bust
i've heard players over the years
addressed that some say definitely hall
of fame buzz some say super bowl ring
matt ryan really stopped and gave it
some thought and i think he came up with
kind of a loophole in his mind yeah you
go for the super bowl ring because that
is more like get you the hall of fame
right right hall of fame bus didn't
going to get you a super bowl ring so i
like that i like that way to navigate
through the the dilemma and and find a
way to basically say both without saying
both yeah well exactly though but i
think that was when i saw the question
posed here on our little document that
we have and i hadn't heard his answer i
thought i'd want a super bowl ring more
likely if you've had a pretty good
career and then get the super bowl
you'll end up in the hall of fame but
all these guys are playing for super
bowl rings they are and that's a special
thing to have i mean damn when my dad
brings out his two super bowl rings
still i'm still like a kid in a candy
store when i see them i'm just like oh
my gosh look at these things this is so
cool i mean uh so it's a special thing
and you know of course be able to say
you're the champion and the best in the
world at what you do is also special to
any competitor
but here's the thing
there are plenty of guys
who never actually played in a game
regular season postseason right who have
super bowl rings there are plenty of
people who never put on a helmet other
than part of a halloween costume who
have super bowl rings
so i i now yeah i think that's what
signifies right but but still if you're
matt ryan and you have a super bowl ring
it's not going to be because you're
working as a scout for the falcons
you've earned it as the starting
quarterback so it signifies so much more
to him and and i think it makes sense
because look even though
there are so many other factors that go
into it i mean look at his 2016 season
he's the regular season mvp he did
everything he could to set the table for
the falcons to win super bowl 51 they
were up 28 to three and then the defense
fell apart now now look there were some
issues with the offense down the stretch
when it came to holding the lead but
still as as as we list the people
responsible for that disaster for the
falcons matt ryan is fairly far down on
the list of people responsible for
blowing the 28-3 lead so he did
everything he could he put all the hay
in the barn and then somebody threw a
cigarette in there yeah and uh so so
here's the question yeah is what he did
in 2016 more impressive than eli manning
and his two super bowl mvps that capped
seasons where you know it was almost
like a slumdog millionaire vibe things
fell together just right for the giants
and everything worked and it clicked and
eli manning makes a couple of throws for
the ages what's more impressive what
ryan did in 2016 or what eli did in 2007
and 2011. wow i mean what ryan did was i
mean he was a machine that year he
really was now he had kyle shanahan with
him and of course talent around him and
there was a lot of plays served up on a
silver platter to go like hey here's
julio jones he's wide open over the
middle for a 20-yard gain nobody's
around him if you can just hit him it's
a first down and there was a lot of that
it was impressive i think i would go
with eli manning though i think i would
you know there's something to be said
about the biggest game the biggest
moment of your life
coming through in that moment and
especially an eli manning situation
coming against
the freaking undefeated new england
patriots and then having to deal with
the patriots again and being on your own
two yard line and the mario manningham
throw and all that so hey listen we
could sit here and argue that eli
probably didn't deserve the first mvp i
mean i think michael strahan or or
justin tuck or somebody like that
probably should have got it but
regardless i think you know coming back
against that patriots team some of those
big throws and that big play to david
tyree and all that yeah i think i'd
probably favor the eli manning thing
over the matt ryan
yeah week in and week out the matt ryan
2016 season more impressive but there's
something about emerging with the super
bowl mvp award especially doing it twice
uh and you you ask anybody that wins the
regular season mvp over the past 20
years because not since kurt warner has
there been a double
regular season mvp super bowl mvp for 20
years the regular season mvp has not won
the super bowl crazy and every one of
those guys would tell you
my season was not a success
who cares about the regular season mvp i
wanted that super bowl ring that's what
they all want that's why they do it
that's the motivation and matt ryan
still has that motivation and maybe
maybe look in this crazy hey we talked
earlier about it chris they've got a set
up at training camp where they have
individual town homes where guys have
their own bathrooms they have their own
changing area to the extent that guys
need to feel comfortable this year
they're going to feel comfortable
in the falcons facility and
that goes a long way towards you guys
healthy keeping your guys focused if
these other teams are in disarray if
these other teams have a bunch of guys
who are on the covet 19 list it's going
to make it easier for the falcons to win
games no doubt i mean yeah it looks like
they got a formula that's going to keep
their players safe and on the field and
things like that to where maybe they
won't be ravished by the the the virus
and everything there so that's going to
be part of the game this year and you
know you heard matt ryan in your
interview there too talk about
you know i go home but we've created our
own little bubble within our personal
life to me that is going to be the great
importance that i hope the matt ryans
and the grady jareds of the world for
each team continue to preach that to the
guys in their locker room like hey
i mean do you want a super bowl ring
this year do you want that you know
you know a few million dollars worth of
checks you're gonna get this year okay
well go home and do the right damn thing
like make sure yeah okay i understand
your your kids and your wife and
everything aren't just gonna sit there
and wait for you to get home but make
sure they're around people you trust and
you know don't have the branches and
tentacles two out you know reaching out
into society i think that's going to be
a big part i mean i know my wife and i
we've had this conversation a lot lately
we were just sitting around and
spitballing and whatever and we put
ourselves in this situation and she was
just like oh i mean if you were making
like quarterback money and doing that
and still playing i i would never leave
the house we might not send the kids to
school we might just stay in the house
and you go to football and come home and
do all that and i'm like yeah i think
that's the kind of thing that you'd
probably have to do if you want to be
successful
all right we need to take a break coming
up the next team on our pre-season power
rankings the new york
jets sam darnold says he has a lot more
confidence this year
uh and uh there's plenty of ghost gifts
that have been posted on twitter in
response to
to that comment from sam darnold we'll
be talking more about the 2020 jets when
pf2 live continued for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports